foreign
this show is brought to you by texture
gain access to all the top magazines
including back issues and bonus video
content at texture.com Joey
and the best part texture is offering
our listeners a free trial right now
when you go to texture.com Joey that's
texture.com Joey and the show is brought
to you by me undies go to meundies.com
Joey right now and check out all of
their men's and women's underwear socks
T-shirts they have amazing clothing
that's the most comfortable you're ever
going to wear and the best part shipping
is free in the US and Canada when you go
to meandies.com Joey and you also get 20
off of your first order that's me
undies.com Joey and go to audit.com and
use code word church to save 10 on all
of the great optimization products like
Alpha Brain new mood stream tech immune
and shroom Tech sport
oh [__]
foreign
there's some real heroin music
Monday night [__]
June 6th
6 6 16.
I haven't heard this album in [__]
years I put on me all day
I almost shot myself is this the one
with loud love on it
no this is the one with this is bad
motorcycle oh yeah yeah
I like loud love
what's the name of that Lounge Louder
Than Love or something is it on that is
it on Louder Than Love Love
[Applause]
are you kidding me or what
thank you
Lee Syed Mark Maron
Uncle Joey
what's going on there guys
loud love is on uh Louder Than Love yeah
yeah it's on the number seven yeah
that's a good one that's a great that's
a great album yeah there was a period
there where I was just cramming those
guys into my head every day for like two
years right that's what I listen to it's
weird like that when I look at records
because like some records I don't listen
to anymore and then I'll I'll put it on
and I'm like I know this [__] record
and it was because of when I got it I
never stopped listening to it over and
over again and then it just kind of goes
into the back file I will play the [__]
out of an album yeah for six seven
months if it gets me going and to be
honest with you all these albums I
played the [__] out of growing up Led
Zeppelin too I I I [__] did
everything to this song Here seven
Bloody Sabbath I just got into that one
oh my God I woke up to that song still
on a Monday morning I played this at 6am
at the [__] house cyber buddy Sabbath
yeah I just started listening to Sabbath
buddy good [__] hours
Santana braxus when I was I don't even
know what the [__] Santana was I ordered
this on Columbia House when they would
send you oh yeah
you'd have to get your parents to pay
for it eventually yeah yeah eventually
the collectors start coming [__] you I I
had like I would send them on the other
people's money yeah yeah like the people
next door and the people next door the
records will come every month you're
like I didn't ask for this record [__]
who the [__] wants this Dan Fogelberg
record okay now what it is they were
signed up they were such they were
already bootlegging albums 50 years ago
Colombia yeah that's how they made their
money is that true yeah if you went and
bought Savage Bloody Sabbath from a
record store and you bought it from
Colombia oh they did their own pressing
it was probably it was probably in
agreement though yes they did the Dome
pressing so the the cover was different
you're like a real difference
you know I remember some of the records
I got
the smoker you drink that I got that Joe
Walsh record with the Rocky Mountain Way
on it
that is probably 13 or 14 maybe 12. I
got a ELO's Greatest Hits For some
reason I got the first Aerosmith record
I remember those three I remember Rocky
Mountain ways spent the last year I
wasn't even a third that cool you know
what I got what Tom McQueen American
Empire I already had that guy I already
had that guy that's what I ordered the
first time yeah some BG album it wasn't
signing out live no it's before so those
they weren't bad then before the uh
before the Disco thing they were all
right that [__] out my oldest abraxis
yep
like uh Earth wouldn't fire out my order
yeah that's it that's good and you
didn't get to choose right it was just
you sent in another stuff and that was
the ad get nine albums for one penny oh
that was so you marked just boxes and
then you put one you had a choice though
you you Scotch tape get a list and you
just mailed it postage was already paid
for nothing an idiot could do it they
had a list of right they had a list yeah
everybody at that time they had all the
hot albums tapping into me or anything
that was everything that was hot in that
[__] time and Joey was rocking out
the Muskrat Love back in the whole day I
had when I first moved sounds the
captain when I first [__] over
Columbia House I [__] them for garbage
yeah
then I got hip and I started sending
them to people's houses on my block
Janine tristano but you go check the
mail you say my [__] come yet I should
stay outside
the box off you knew what the box looked
like you had either nine cassettes in
there or eight tracks all the [__]
hours that reminds me of that story
I was just waiting for truck because I
thought there was some blow on it that
was a funny story hit me we're here we
got till 9 30. what's up like when I was
in it when I was doing the blow you know
like I didn't have a hookup I was it I
was at Acme you know I was in
Minneapolis you know it was cold and I
just finished like an eight ball or
something I don't even think it was coke
me and my buddy Iselle finished I think
it was speed
and you know it was like the Saturday I
just wanted some blow so I so I I called
our buddy Bob I'm not gonna use any last
names out here because he had a hookup
and I'm like dude yeah could you just
I'll FedEx you money for an eight ball
and he FedEx it back so I FedEx the
money for an eight ball I guess FedEx
money you're just putting money without
cash money yeah and I sent it to him and
he was going to FedEx it right back and
he goes okay I did it it's coming he
said I hit it in some peanut butter it's
in a bag and he had a big story he had a
tracking number and the next day I'm in
front of the [__] club waiting
waiting for that goddamn FedEx truck and
I and it pulls up and I and I'm like do
you have a package Mark Maron care of
Acme and the guys are could you get off
the truck
no package the guy [__] me like
there's nothing more disappointing than
being led that far down the line with it
like it's coming it's in it wasn't in
peanut butter that's someone else's
story that I remember that story it was
he said he packed it in a videotape that
he opened like to hit to hide it yeah
had a whole [__] thing and it didn't
come and it was it was heartbreaking
Joey heartbreak it's the Heartbreak you
know you're you just think you're gonna
be good that's such a scumbag move
because your heart they don't understand
that yeah no [__] understatement but
he went and got an eight ball with my
money he made good on it later years
later I used to have it when I first
moved to Basalt Colorado
I would you know my God that I didn't
want the cat to get out of the bag so I
controlled myself for a few weeks yeah
so the guys I was living with there was
one guy that he'd always be sniffling I
know what time it was yeah yeah and one
day uh you know we got in the
conversation like I love to do a line
now and he's like oh I can't
cops and all this [__] and I I knew his
brothers I grew up with him
you know he was just a scumbag this guy
so I had two other roommates it was four
of us in this huge house and one day I
hear him on the phone just send it to
the P.O box and so he would go to work
I'd take his pee he would leave the key
hanging yeah I'd take the key I
hitchhike a ride to Aspen and then go to
the mailbox and there it was the guy
would send him an eight ball from here
yeah and after like three of them I
would hear him arguing with the guy I
didn't [__] get it I'm telling you
I'm gonna have to go down there and I'm
giggling the room doing the [__] Coke
you know I would stealing right from the
[__] post office who gives a what's
the post listen the post office is gonna
rob you yeah sixty percent of the
[__] is that true especially if you
send weed from here and [__] they'll get
the envelope ripped open
you mean they'll just they'll just yank
it out of the bag these postmen oh oh
they take the postman take it they're
not throwing it away no it's being used
nobody [__] takes some weed and
throws I'm an American they throw it
away they're gonna call the cops right
go down 9-1-1 so they just smell it and
they're like Curious yeah well did you
guys ever worry about that because you
always hear stories about like some like
FBI agents or whatever posing as FedEx
people and as soon as you accept the
package they arrest you why ain't in the
racket anymore so I don't have to worry
about it the thing is that you don't
have to do that with weed anymore no one
has to send weed anywhere you could send
Coke one time
like if you're in a bind and you send me
like toys for Mercy you could say I put
some Mexican in there for you
and when I get the box once you do it
every week like those guys that get
busted yeah that's because they do it
every week and there's a bird somebody
says hey they're sending Coke or
something like that but an eight ball
it's amazing I had a friend that would
fly every week with an eight ball and an
envelope and yeah in his [__] grind
it up in his wallet in the plane they're
not looking for that [__] right through
in his wallet like next to his credit
card it's a little bundle with a [__]
eight ball in it grind it up you're not
looking for that okay because I have a
question I got pulled twice because I
wouldn't oh they pulled you on the way
back dude on the way back so I'm not
sure if there's just a number of TSA
when they just when they pull you aside
or if there's actually something I don't
know maybe my detergent but I got pulled
twice maybe they found out they got
ejected from the south point and you're
an international [__] THC Smuggler
who the [__] knows you know what's you
know what uh sets the bomb dogs or the
my chick was uh she had cut and she put
hydrogen peroxide on it done next day
she went to the the to the airport and
they they did a read on her and she had
to get searched from that from hydrogen
peroxide Lysol I have sleep apnea
machine yeah so I wipe it every night
and oh it does it too yeah so I have it
on my hands I wipe it before I put in
the bags no germs growing there with the
lights off nine out of ten times do you
know right after 9 11 they pulled me off
a [__] plane
for what after the fact they came Joe
Jose Diaz please come to the [__]
front gate that came up they go we gotta
hold you to the next flight thank God it
was those Tempe flights yeah every hour
yeah right it wasn't Southwest it was
the other company that goes there yeah
not that tran but somebody else goes
from LAX JetBlue no no no one of those
weirdo and spirit or I only mentioned
Spirit to Uncle Joe what did what that
what is that that's right Cuban Airlines
the worst is Frontier that's the Cuban
animal all right you don't know if
you're gonna get there you don't know
where you're gonna land and even though
you just give them money it's like a
[__] Magical Mystery you know when
you tell you play those fights like you
go to like a Miami airport and you see
like Spirit or something and you look at
the waiting there you're like what the
[__] is going on I took Spirits once I
couldn't even stand up the roads are so
close together oh no no no you make a
big mistake with those those are a one
time I'll never do those again the one
that ain't bad which one the one you
said before JetBlue no no
that's what I just took it was great
JetBlue is nice a lot of people like
Jeopardy I liked it at the beginning
because it was new planes that these new
French planes really nicely built you
know all the seats were comfortable
everyone had a TV set but then after a
while you're like Yeah The Blue Chips
aren't you know they're all right but
yeah I'd like the option of maybe
upgrading to a bigger class you know you
want to have the option and I don't pay
for first class but if I get the points
like eventually you gotta commit I gotta
commit to American and I'll fly all the
time I'm [__] American just so I can
get on the plane first with my bag and I
don't have to check [__] that's me yeah
so I just want to have that status give
me a little status if you start just
going you know piecemeal like you know
this cheap one here just so you do uh no
you're dead no you didn't get no no you
got no royalty No One's Gonna help you
out you're nobody you know 15 16 years
ago there was a place by the airport
yeah that you took a ticket went online
they got you the cheapest available seat
the day before right cheatpad.com I
think that's still around whatever the
[__] they were
they used used to be able to go to the
website I'd be at the Miami Improv and I
never had plans to take the [__] uh
train to South Carolina the Myrtle Beach
but I'd go on there and I get like 49
flights that same day before day before
because they just want to filter Beach
Myrtle Beach to NYC you know Kennedy
that this is way prior to 9 11. but also
since 98.99 there was fewer planes so it
was a big deal now it's like yeah it's
like you can find a flight for a
reasonable price right I mean but the
sum of the flights went up again
and you sit there is it bad it's [__]
bad I've seen some of those I was
supposed to be in Albany this week if I
tell you what they wanted for the flight
to Albany I know who covered the week
and I called them and said we got flying
at Buffalo you got to fly into [__]
JFK and take a a little plane right a
little plane
The Base ticket was 606 on American
round trip round trip the little one all
the way at the end was 606 and when you
went to those flight things there were
598 nothing 596. same thing so by the
time you pay taxes it's 607 yeah and
you're like what the [__] I could have
got my points and flown like a doctor
and at least been able to negotiate with
upgrade now you blew your [__]
upgrade right now you blew the [__]
up Hey listen I live on upgrades I'm
upgrading with the airline American me
too I know exactly where they're gonna
upgrade me and where they're not going
to upgrade you to Chicago JFK no
I got it one time I got business section
on the way back right very tough to go
to JFK those tickets 2300 yeah to JFK
look I'm not police I had to go next
week from LAX to JFK on American yeah I
don't you got to find the JFK laguardies
oh no LaGuardia tonight the worst what
the [__] JFK is crackalackin like a
[__] did you ever read that
article about how they stack planes up
over the [__] those here I don't even
want to know about it I think it was
LaGuardia well sometimes they get like a
dozen circling in layers like they're
just like a tier of circling airplanes
waiting to I don't even want to think
about it because when you like when you
watch LAX those air those planes coming
in every two seconds they got a circle
so they they just route them so like
these air traffic controllers they got
it's like psychedelic they got just
vertical spirals of circling airplanes
waiting to come in and it's just I don't
I can't even think about it and
LaGuardia is supposed to be going the
worst with that horse how much uh just
it's loading I did the Thursday to
Sunday to see what it would be what's
that for J from to JFK from here um
all right so you want first class no no
just basic JFK okay basic is 634 for the
6am I should go no no I'm just saying 10
years ago every flight was three bills
right 340. that's one way one way yeah
yeah oh yeah dog I'm telling you I think
so it's summertime that's slinging dick
now you might as well go there with your
[__] out and go take me I'm yours
this Platinum [__] card they give you
from America oh wait no no it could be
round trip if you want to take this exam
flight back 6 a.m six bills six [__]
Bells yeah six barrels let's say you got
a family of four that 24 right off the
bat the Uber 2500 for Uber in a [__]
plane ticket
that's if you have a family of four and
you want to go back East with your
family you know family of two kids and
you and your wife it's 2500 with the
Uber and American Airlines and you're
right first class is 2409
everything's an upgrade so yeah all
those guys that take that flight a
business guys they laugh at Americans
face I did enough road work I got
executive Platinum last year I think I'm
still holding the executive Platinum I
think I'm Platinum yeah what's exactly
yeah yeah but like it means something
like sometimes you can upgrade American
internet I know who's Pate who's banging
oh Delta [__] like that listen
Delta's got the best flight into JFK
yeah you know some people don't go go
see what the price is saying I've not
had great experience with that Delta
first with their time is tremendous it's
better than American First Class yes
they treat you like a human being number
one number two
they got better food and number three if
you find um they have that one program
where you check in they give you a drink
in the morning oh yeah your thing yeah
they got beds yeah or where it's in the
lounge Delta's got beds that go down on
the plane oh no they got those on
American now where you get your only
beginning get your own apartment yeah
you got your own [__] a little burner
that's why they charge you the 24 bills
on American because that's the first
first class not business no no business
you get pretty close to laying down but
not quite laying down first class you
get an apartment right first class
business is regular first class in
American like if you go to Kentucky from
[__] how much Delta all right let's
oh
a little bit it's 6 28
but it actually first class is only
22.45 yeah they always try what are you
talking about yeah it's like three three
dollars less it's 150 bucks so everybody
who takes that flight no one's paying
for it at their own pocket he's paying
for it so everything isn't upgrade so an
upgrade or they're being flown by the
company that right so I feel like wow
there you hit it on that that's where
you gotta that's what you're working for
not the big money you're working for
someone to fly you first class somewhere
I'll do the gig find me First Class get
on the plane first if you tell the
improvs to fire first class they'll
they'll fly you first class with your
own money they'll take that out of your
check one way or another yeah yeah right
or wrong that every Comedy Club will
tell you first class yeah you and your
buddies absolutely sure sure yeah
everybody you want champagne on the
first time you have your house is
papered oh my God you got a [__] bill
at the end because those four [__]
Savages you brought with you they ate
and drank all weekend like I said they
thought everything is on their own and
also the guy goes to the back and goes
what happened to the [__] no one's
getting paid
let me ask you something right I was
watching uh you know promotion sent me
the trailer today a view of you and I
and I'm great and I'm watching you and
it's doing a great shooting days I'm
thinking about Joey and the rooster did
you make a short films
I gotta get you I wish I could get those
outtakes I should just pull those out I
was so scared of chicken I couldn't
believe it it was the best thing what
were you gonna say I'll tell the story
in a minute
story you're watching say to you though
I'm watching this Trail and I'm watching
you
I knew
one of the creepiest [__] nights I
gotta tell you I had in L.A
I had to think hard about this I've had
like three Creepy Nights and all of them
were in the coaching horses oh yeah all
of them I had to go to the coaching
horses yeah guys the coaching horses was
a real old school bar with LA people and
a couple of creepy ones yeah that was a
creepy Place dude I had one yeah but one
night I was in there you John
out of my mind yeah I got some coke and
Silver Lake by that Cuban bakery up
there listen to me I was going to an
audition and I got lost yeah and I go
down this block and I hear gunshots yeah
you can't write this [__] [__] this
could only happen to Uncle Joe yeah and
I pull over and I look up and the guys
gotta the cops got a shotgun and the
guys on the [__] floor and people
were running and the guy's got a gun and
so I'm sitting there watching this [__]
and also when I go to cut over and I
hear Boom and my tire goes out
what the [__]
it's 3 35 I just got up here I got out
of traffic I got a little lost not in
the helicopters are flying around me my
flat tire goes up what am I gonna do
I didn't even have a [__] cell phone
those days I pulled over and I went up
to whatever Sunset is and I called
Marilyn Martinez Marlon Martinez lived
in Silver Lake at the time when it was
broken down this is the 98th when the
[__] was going down 99 you were here wow
99. yeah 98 you were here 97. it was my
first year here I was coming out here
and there I didn't live here yeah so I
go to uh the husband comes over we take
the tile we go to that neighbor they got
those tired things on the hill up yeah
on Sunset if you keep going up in Silver
Lake they got those five hours they got
a tire for you how much you got four
dollars hold on yeah that comes back
yeah yeah he puts crazy glue in the hole
so I put one of those tires on and all
of a sudden I started talking to Dave
was the guy's name
and he goes you know my brother-in-law's
Cuban he just got out of doing 11 years
for distribution I said no [__] he goes
you want to meet and I go yeah let's go
over there and talk to Mike go over
there he's got these Saints they just
killed the chicken they're dressed in
white my type of [__] Cubans I start
talking
two two three minutes and the guy right
off the bat goes get him pass it
yeah absolutely he comes out takes a
rock out of a suitcase
I do a line dog it's 3 30 by this time
it's 4 30. I do a line I'm electrified
yeah now my number one rule was no coke
before I went on stage right
no middle of the day not even in the
middle of the day because that fumes
were getting to my stand up I just had
this rule I didn't care when I saw that
rock that he took out a shiny it was
like that old China White Pearl this is
97 this guy just got out of jail how
great is it to listen to oh drug fans
talk about drugs so and the craziest
thing is I've been with him for five
years I don't this is the furthest from
what I've seen so that's why it's so
crazy to me because it's like it's
unbelievable so
talking one
and one thing goes you ain't call me
anytime you need something he goes do
you want to take something like I don't
have no money because nobody comes to my
house only because back in this doctor's
bag
it takes out three quarters of a gebo
who's better than me I'm happy as [__]
yeah but there's only one problem and I
gotta look you in there I tell you this
I am so [__] up on that little line I
did
I can't leave
I was electrified like it was eight
nineteen eighties Coke my hair's been
sticking up my pupils are dilated and
all I could taste is a Budweiser in a
can yeah and I get in the car and I'm
out there enjoying my brains out I had
to hide the [__] Coke in the spare
tire under the [__] thing and all I
had to do was get to at that time God
knows where the [__] I lived I lived
somewhere in Hollywood all I had to do
is get home I get home guess what I put
away the package like a gentleman I got
like in those days Mitzi used to lurk
yeah you know you cancel the midst in
those days it was two weeks without a
spot I haven't yeah
so it was like a Tuesday night I do the
spot it's it's it's black night yeah and
I got on there and all of a sudden I do
two bumps of this [__] let me tell you
something I'm the laziest [__] in the
world I walk from the store directly to
coaching horses there's a liquor store
after the store after the store you go
to coaching horses I mean there's a
liquor store let me tell you how much I
drank like when I used to do I don't
drink yeah I don't like it but in those
days once I did the third line yeah it
was over yeah well you see these guys I
don't drink anybody under the table
you're not gonna [__] with Joey Diaz
trust me yeah and I remember walking
from the store and the first liquor
store I stopped was by the Chateau
Marmont
and then I drank a [__] Budweiser
like a Savage New York's professional
yeah
when I was joining the coke is in my
throat and there was that sweet Chinese
a taste it and I walked all the way up
to another liquor store was past Fairfax
next to the Kentucky Fried Chicken yeah
with a Blockbuster Video used to be yeah
I got another can of beer there boom I'm
[__] up I'm going in the bushes I'm
taking powder I'm doing it in my nose
meanwhile so is anything going like
what's happened because up or down it's
an upper downer all around her yeah he's
sweating and he's looking around walking
on Sunset on Sunset it's 11 15. I'm
headed to the coaching horses oh that
place I walk in the coaching horses it's
you Schubert
Dave Fulton we were there everybody like
10 comics were there and everybody was
[__] doing blast I remember going to
that bathroom and the bathroom was small
remember Dave yeah he's like he's in
England or something I'm putting water
in my nose and I was parked
Josh Wolf's block
that's where I lived in the car
part-time and in this house part time
parked over then I got so I saw you guys
I said two or three words to you guys I
couldn't talk and that cocaine ain't
High when you can't do it that's how
good the blower yeah like I couldn't
talk yeah and I still had a [__] four
tenths of a g-ball left I'm on fire I
gotta go somewhere in jerk off yeah
what's a gebo a gram okay so I got it
yeah and Joey speak and I gotta bang one
huh yeah you gotta get down you gotta
get [__] it yeah come down with a focus
I [__] crossed the street and there's
a 7-Eleven yeah on Curson yeah I bought
a can of being I ran to that [__] car
hey I put the air on I put the seat back
and I bang two good ones out it took me
an hour and a half of sweating and
putting Coke on my dick and [__]
[Music]
you felt better though oh my God I came
and then I could the paranoia went away
the initial paranoid go back to the bar
and I went back to coaching horses and
you guys were leaving with broads they
were broads and you guys were going to
somebody's house and I was too coked out
to even have a conversation but I knew
that going in yeah that that bar was
evil that bar was evil and I wasn't
gonna you know you ever get those guys
that are annoying and then they show up
and now they can't talk and they're
drinking I didn't want to be that guy
that was my guy well there was always
like a contingent of like relatively
healthy kind of young people and then
there was always these old [__]
druggies there like one oh yeah it was a
yeah
just [__] just who jerks off yeah I
was gonna say on a car around the corner
from Malcolm Padres didn't like you know
at one time I jerked off on like a clean
shirt yeah and the other time like a
pillow okay I mean it was just it was a
way to get down you know what I mean if
you didn't have nothing to get you down
it was a way just to [__] get
whatever oh my God I I just remembered
that was one of the first times I saw
you like rocking and nobody was talking
nobody everybody was at the bar elbows
up looking straight ahead yeah I used to
go there occasionally when I was in town
doing that [__] yeah Jimmy was always
kind of like he'd go right to like
what's going with you you hear something
like you know it was never was he it was
it but be a line out he'd do it and then
it's like check your closets it was it
was no good time in between you know the
line and you know checking the closets
you know what I mean I was shooting the
movie basketball yeah
I come to town they sent me the 20th
Century Fox yeah and they tell them
and they go go and go NYPD Blue yeah I
go to NYPD Blue eat a bag of [__] it's
nine pages Spanish English I can't cut
this I'm walking back and as I'm walking
a lady pops on goes are you here for the
audition
yeah she looks at me like yeah and she
gives me this sign she can learn them
and come back in five minutes I go but I
don't know nothing about nothing Mark
married not even a school play yeah okay
I'm going
I read thank you for coming in all right
oh my God I'm living in a hotel on
Schrader there's a hostel it's not it's
now a hostel then it was uh 27 a day you
got a three week limit SRO oh my God I
would go there every night with you have
a hot plate uh no I just stayed on
Hollywood Boulevard and got malaria and
everything else that comes with it I
[__] I lived in that place because
you could only live there for three
weeks of the shot yeah so I lived there
for two weeks go on the road 10 days go
on the road so I never met many years
this is 90 [__] seven
yeah and when they call it was like the
rocky Hotel yeah somebody who goes there
with Joey Diaz in the hallway in the
hallway Payphone in the hallway hey you
Joey Diaz yeah you got to call
downstairs I remember walking downstairs
picking up the phone like hey man
it's your manager Ken folks what's up
Ken listen I gotta you got the movie
basketball
she had three weeks 5500 a week
5500 in the back of my mind I'm like
that's about 50 [__] Grand everything
you could talk about when you're [__]
when you're doing blow every time
somebody talks to you like how much is
it pay 250 you're like uh that's a half
eight ball I can make my car payment you
know but every time with some amount of
coke came into that math figure
so when you hear 50 000 oh my fifty five
hundred for three weeks but there was a
catch I had to pay for my own sag APA
got them to [__] wave the fee mother
Taft Hartley no no pay it you're in the
mood The Producers paid it right in
those days they would talk to Purdue you
one of them you got to pay the producers
boom they put me in that dog I was a I
was out 24-hour medicine there because
I'm a comic yeah I don't know what it is
to wait yeah how much longer two more
hours
sitting in the trailer yeah practicing
roller skate yeah So eventually the
street in me came out what do you think
I started doing on roller skates from
the big truck they had a big truck they
had like 18 pairs of 13. so you're
waiting to shoot and you're stealing
every night I'm taking a pair of roller
stickers taking out the ski chalet three
bills plus tax I'm taking back cash
every day Ah that's not how to wait till
one guy got off one guy got back on
every day they finally knew it they're
like what the weekend on top of 5500 a
week yeah and I didn't even get a check
and now I'm living on 15 checks and
living at a hostel you know and all of a
sudden I'm stealing roller skates every
listen but now there's like 10 other
guys telling the story from the other
side we had this guy oh my God I think
his name was Joe stealing [__] skates
every night thinking no one knew it oh
my God every night until they they only
had like up to size six and a half
but here's the Clinton for two weeks I'm
in the everyday six to nine nobody says
two words to me I'm sitting there
watching McCarthy the chick doing
[__] hitting up Jenny with a monkey
sweating yeah she's out there 90 degree
weather doing karate that was my
highlight of the day watching her work
so one night I go to the store who do I
team up with
Jenny McCarthy Jimmy Two Shoes oh yeah
boom yeah
don't worry about it when you get paid
you come to see me you know he had just
gotten this deal he's out there [__]
every night he got the leather jacket
yeah you got the [__] Camry remember
what you think camera what do you think
it's the first Toyota in my family
tremendous I team up with that lunatic
and we go up to Los Feliz when he lived
up on the hill there
I gotta tell you Mark Maron with a
couple bumps next thing you know we're
both on the floor yeah crawling because
it was somebody outside
because I was a good time oh my God I
was okay in those days until you got
creepy yeah like once I caught you
looking out the window that's it that's
all you needed yeah that's it there went
the night okay that eight ball is done
some either you're gonna snort it or
we're gonna throw it away because
there's cops out there I never got that
I was never that guy 20 years of doing
blow you never got paranoid well no I
didn't I didn't I don't know why I see
somebody get paranoid yeah who a lot of
people well Jimmy's get like yeah but
some guys just did that you know so that
was that was what happened
you know what I mean it was like it was
just it was a certain type of guy you
know I just never it was never my thing
I would get uh yeah I never got the
[__] paranoid thing
oh my God I was fine I get more Paranoid
on weed for years I was fine I was a
soldier at that well that's what happens
yeah six and a half a year more it was
seeing things and hearing things oh well
no okay well yeah when I thought when I
hit the wall oh yeah
oh please I hit the wall when I hit the
wall there's a lot of voices but the
paranoia wasn't about cops it was about
like [__] like aliens oh yeah no no
there was no aliens in my world not
aliens but somebody the forces I
understood the forces of evil and there
was people that might be working for him
like people I knew is like that's one of
them he's undercover for the forces that
he like I was [__] up oh my god with
the uh with the psychosis but never like
on a casual night that I think cops were
coming but when I finally lost my mind
I'm pretty sure I was at the store I'm
like I'm a secret agent I'm supposed to
be here for for to understand what's
going on here Satan's got a hold of this
place and it's I got to spread the word
some I didn't yeah I had to go I had to
go yeah I had a conversation with lito
one in the morning after The Comedy
Store
and I shook while I was telling Lee and
I shook on until I went to my living
room and took a [__] Xanax like a 0.5
I shook just going talking about it you
know uh learning about
psychology what psychology means you
know
you know I was telling me one night I
ran out of Bloom in Boulder Colorado
it's two in the morning yeah I call my
roommate my roommate's a deal I can't
[__] find this boy call him up here
come over here it's a party I go over
there there's like eight people laying
around this blower when I'm doing little
bumps
I go where's the back like the one in
the back clogged up you have to go
downstairs and go downstairs it's a
check down it says another chick and I
pee and I come out and she's like you
want to do a line I do a line with it
just tell me about her kids how she's
married you know tomorrow what is she
gonna do it's two in the morning she has
to go to Little League game at nine in
the morning horrible next thing you know
she's like you want to play a big game
of ping pong yeah yeah
next thing you know
if you want to gamble
a gamble dollar game
is yeah [__] sunsets coming up she
starts telling me like you want to
gamble and play strip
you know make dog I'm up for anything
man this girl was 34. hot yeah you know
where's your husband watching the kids
oh I'm playing she's completely naked
next you know we're banging the ping
pong tables yeah and you can't explain
this to people next you know she just
gets up like nothing happened I gotta
play nothing happened with my life yeah
until a week later there you go I slept
with a married woman with kids yeah she
sucked my dick with a Coke rock on it
over a ping pong table you know and she
got up went and went to a little league
well it's like a different time zone you
know you enter this Zone when you're up
no I'm shaking yeah well you do those
all night things like all of a sudden
like it's like the middle of the night
you don't know what time it is
everyone's jacked on coke and [__]
happens weird [__] happens it takes a
couple of days to get back to normal
time zone but then you're sort of like
what the [__] was that and then you see
the person again maybe like yeah don't
talk about it is it like you know
sometimes I say like stuff when you're
drunk but you really want comes out is
it that it like when you're on coke is
it what you really want well no it's
just like weird magic happens like it's
some dark energy that I'm good where
where like you know things just become
possible that weren't possible it's not
like you're saying things you don't want
it's just like [__] gets weird one thing
will happen and then you're like is this
happening and then it's just [__] just
[__] gets weird it's like that you
know when I was oh man you just see
people come and go you lose sense of
time sometimes days go by and characters
come and go and [__] happens like when I
was hanging up there at the store like
you know all that [__] with Sam and then
just like normal [__] where you go on
these three day runs because we didn't
have nothing to do and the no cover
night was Monday night so the party
would start then sometimes it would go
to Wednesday and you don't know what the
[__] happened or like someone so there's
a woman needs to climb in our window
she's the crying she could come in the
door but she climb in the [__] window
for some reason and she'd make out and
do [__] with me and some and then
Schubert and then like she disappeared
and now like years later I think she's a
school teacher now I don't know
sometimes you're just somebody's bad
face you know they've moved they move
through and then they go on to have
regular lives and we're we're here
talking about the other side of it
but I feel guilty like sometimes you go
Jesus [__] Christ what did
like I started in 1979 yeah
started getting crazy well you I mean
you're like a a Jedi master of it like I
don't I don't think I got as far out but
maybe I'd give myself you know a break
but like you know I after the first
psychosis
you know I I knew that there was a
problem with that it didn't stop me I'd
stop here and there for a while but you
know it just got [__] scary
for me it got scarier like in 84. after
like five years of [__] going nuts
with it like I didn't even think of
stopping
till 84. though [__] was I was living
under a rocket ship in northern New
Jersey
a rocket ship like a at the park yeah at
the park are you sleeping outside oh it
was [__] terrible
like yeah then I got cleaned up for a
long time I always swept indoors oh yeah
horrible in November and then I got
cleaned up for a while and then I went
into this other deeper section and then
I found out years later that you know
even when you stopped doing blow the
addiction still grows
so now I'm dealing with ounces Mark
Maron right I remember yeah wake up
there's an eight ball you're like I
really did 21 Grams last night oh that's
[__] hard but you're lucky to be
alive you know like you look at you know
God gives you a certain beats right but
you know what [__] me is that like all
that crazy [__] when I was when I got
into that psychotic State I was at the
store it was the late 80s and I was
really out of my mind and then it took
like a year and a half two years to
shake the [__] weirdness to shake the
I'd go to the store and it just
re-triggered and be like it's still
[__] up like it took like two years to
get my brain back to where that was just
a building and you know I wasn't on some
sort of secret mission
from the forces of whatever like I get
right right when I got to La I'd see the
[__] Haze over the city I'm like I'm
back in it I better start taking notes
because there's going to be questions
[Music]
I don't know when it's gonna happen but
I'm gonna be summoned but it took a long
time I was so happy when that [__] went
away
and that show that we're doing is
tomorrow night man we should tell people
no no people watching right now people
watch them but they'll get it tonight
this will be up an hour after the show
ends right well the uh yeah our episodes
tomorrow night it was great I looked at
it I saw the cut cut together
beautifully but boy that was the you and
the rooster man that [__] chicken we
[__] did can I tell the real story
about this because you were a [__]
Trooper you really [__] because I I
mean I called you on a day's notice go
go go so here's what happens
we wrote this [__] episode right and
I called like I I I I I'll be honest
with the viewers you know Artie Lang was
cast in this part Artie Lange and we
wrote the [__] thing for him right
and uh and then like two days what was
it two days before I get a call from
Artie he's like I I can't you know I
thought it was only going to be a day
I'm like no it's the full [__]
episode you're gonna always like I
thought it was gonna be I got a gig in
New Jersey I can't be out there I don't
know what to do like you know already
worked up he's afraid he's gonna relapse
he's got this he's got he's gonna make
more money on these gigs he's giving me
and I'm like dude forget it just forget
it I hang up the phone I'm like I don't
know what we're gonna do and this kid
who's a writer's assistant this guy Sam
this is young guy he's working as you
know just almost a PA but he's you know
he's he's my guy on set he's like what
about Joey once you have Joey come back
as Bobby and I'm like holy [__] you're a
[__] genius because it was like it
was you and it was better because you
were already established on the show
we've done blow together it was like
that's the way it should have been so I
call you I'm like can you do it like
yeah I'll do it I'll be there tomorrow
what time and we did it and it was I
couldn't even imagine it being with
anybody else like it was the way it was
supposed to be because we already had
the [__] relationship
but I'll tell you there's a scene where
you got I don't even want to tell people
what it is but Bobby Joey's got to
handle a rooster like a live rooster
there's a situation where he's gotta
he's got to pick it up he's gotta walk
with it and I had no idea that this was
Joey's biggest fear and [__] life
like we're like you ready to look at the
we opened the trunk where the rooster is
he's like I can't do this I can't do it
you don't understand I'm Cuban I can't
touch a rooster they're [__] evil I
can't it's just too much and I'm like
are you kidding me you're the guy that
like you know like telling these blow
stories people are shooting guns and
[__] you get a chicken around this guy
he's like oh no no no it's not gonna
happen but he [__] he he steps up he
mans up to the chicken and he's got to
pick it up we got a chicken hand over
there showing you how to handle it and
he picks it up and he does the scene
twice and Rob Cohen's direct and he's
like we got to get it one more time and
Joey's like that's it though one more
time that's it and he picks it up for
the third time and he puts it down and
Rob's like he's like wait maybe we gotta
do and you're like that's it that's it
oh my God I gotta walk away from the
chicken could not [__] like I felt
like we did some real work like we
solved some real childhood trauma oh
do you feel like you you like you're
over it now the chicken fear the reason
I took the chicken I picked up the
chicken as fearful as I am with chickens
I picked it up in this and I thought
about getting needles
I go the quicker I do this yeah I
quickly refinish I can't hold 80 people
yeah if it was just me and Mark might go
[__] himself with this chicken I ain't
picking up this [__] chicken [__] him
Rob Cohen and Rob Cohen's brother and
his uncle but the whole crew can't do
that to people Teamsters people I have a
phobia I have a [__] phobia you know
there's a big rooster too man it was
beautiful yeah he was [__] beautiful
and beautiful and he didn't flick at me
or nothing no with the stuff but yeah
it's uh listen man you have no [__]
life I couldn't believe we got it I was
like I don't know how we're gonna cut
this [__] together but it looks great it
looks great I can't believe that you
just opened up
oh my God I was
you know when you grow up Cuban one day
you're eating cereal and also you hear a
chicken in your bathroom
I'm on 88th Street why is there a
chicken on my back yeah and you open it
at me like Mama there's a chicken yeah
yeah we're gonna do something later with
the chicken
we could just go to the supermarket
Price Right on Broadway so they'd
slaughtered the chicken so they you know
they'd make noises of Santeria and
they'd kill the chicken and I watched it
you know I was the religion thing it's
the religion thing yeah so you get
traumatized but once you make saint
you got to mess with those chickens you
gotta grab them and I would just grab
the chickens and cry and then just drop
it and they gotta grab the chicken
[__] chicken and people would stop
stop the black dude in the conga drums
he's gotta he's got to get the chicken
this went on to my mom gave me a beating
right in the room you got to pick up
such a real [__] trauma oh I hate
that [__] and then I'm in the living on
once we [__] left 88th Street no at
89th Street she had a goat one time
these are white people dentists yeah
she's like hold the elevator
and we gotta go
you know and then one time I saw him was
it in the cage no [__] cage Cubans
don't have caves they don't believe in
cage poachers or 70s it was like they
had them by the horns and they held them
wrestled them
I was I'm a little kid going what the
[__] is that was for Santeria too you
killed a goat and you cook the [__]
goat the monkey too I don't know about
the monkey they had a monkey for some
reason there was a monkey involved I
never saw them
I don't know what happened with the
[__] monkey but I don't think you I
felt like you know it was like it was
like a a weird thing we were walking
through it with you because you got you
know just like that like I was like
really and you're like dude it's one
thing the one thing squirrels rooster
pigeons I [__] hate pigeons more than
chickens and roosters squirrels I don't
even register anymore they're they're
around my house but I don't even notice
him they're like invisible to me I can't
they look at me weird they look at me
this is residual from the culture this
is called the colorado is they're
looking at me weird the squirrels are on
to you since the halfway houses they
were watching me
squirrels around here hilarious one no
but it looks good man it's a funny
episode you know with the girls
everything like it was it really worked
good I was so [__] happy you could do
it and it's so much better I got nothing
against already but Jesus that was some
[__] two days before you gotta shoot
and it was like you were the guy you
were the perfect guy for it well thank
you for giving me the opportunity both
times my friend well the first time I
wrote that for you
I love that [__] episode that led me
loose in a different way like yeah doing
that
like that opportunity let me loose as an
actor I guess I don't know I didn't give
a [__] of that I was so like meticulous
about that episode I want that to be
perfect because you know it's delicate
it's a comedian's episode you know that
story it's just I I love that [__]
episode it might be my favorite episode
of the [__] show like and I don't
know why like I I want to hear from more
comedians about it because it's such a
like it's so specific and so funny you
know the best part of it at the end he's
like I don't [__] care I'm not even
doing a joke anymore that is amazing
I know let's stay out there until the
end selling roller skates and
calendars and [__] you know does it
scare you to think of that I mean is
that like it scared the [__] out of me
man when I started the podcast when I
was looking down at nothing and I had no
dates and I'm like oh the best that
could happen is if I just string along
those like you know those
you'll get into that zone where you're
doing B rooms and you just you know kind
of working Check to Check and I know a
lot of guys do it and I feel for them
and you know and some of them still love
it and I love doing stand-up but I was
terrified of like not having a choice
that was what scared me the most not
having a choice taking whatever I had to
[__] get by like that the idea that
scared me I love doing comedy yeah
and I love doing blah I loved everything
that came with blow I like the line the
borrowing the whole [__] I was really
good at it you know I've been doing it
for a long time
but there was one individual that
changed my whole comedy career his name
was
I know John Fox rest in peace oh the
comic not the booker no from the first
time I met John Fox in the Laugh Factory
yeah he rubbed me the wrong way
because he was already high he was proud
that he was high
she had nothing going on and afterward
he he came right up to me and pitched me
about his whole Rodney resume
and I probably had Coke in my pocket at
that time once I had Coke in my bottle
I'm at peace now you got to give me a
[__] here beating oh yeah how about
something you know that then years ago
the package dance where you're like wait
[__] and then when you feel it you're
like
okay no I'm sorry keep what were you
saying what were you saying and they're
like what happened nothing I got a niche
in my pants yeah but that was the first
time he tried to muscle me and uh he
came to the comedy store later on with
Paul Rodriguez and you know they were
partying everybody was partying at the
store this is 97. I had heard you know
things about John Fox you know all good
things but once I saw him and then I
worked at Myrtle Beach
and he came in to do a guest spot yeah
and he came with this crack chick
she looked like she had sucked a
thousand [__] and Counting and you know
they came in on a scam they wanted to do
a 10-minute guest spot blow up the room
and then sell CDs afterwards so he could
do blow
that's where he was at that's where he
was at 99.
and I'm still seven years away from
doing blow but that memory shocked me
because that was my biggest fear was
ending up on the road telling people
about have you ever seen the movie
basketball yeah I mean it yeah yeah I'm
saying yeah yeah that's true sure you
know I lived in L.A you got to be a
[__] [__] to live in L.A [__]
you know and you sit there in the room
going I'm a feature actor I live in LA
and it's great yeah like that I'm doing
great they told me I wouldn't I'm doing
great now how many of those guys are
still alive really comedy is a different
animal now right if you really think
about comedy no I know never hear a
[__] thing Mark Maron about did you
hear what happened in New Mexico no such
and such got a hammock last week this
guy fell off the stools yeah you're
doing heroin This Guy's in jail those
days are over I mean fed's got that guy
Angels he got went to jail and whatever
did he you got arrested in Arizona for
child support 82 or something like a
miscalculation in New York and they
called the club to him back I don't know
what the deal was but like you know
Angels still parties
wow Angel's still getting down like
check it out yeah he's still getting
down like it and you see him and you're
like you know God bless you yeah I did
not want to be that guy I didn't mean
either because after a certain age it's
on you you know it's like right now when
was the last time somebody came up to
you said Mark I got this [__] Coke I
got it from [__] no way no way
anymore nobody comes on time because
it's an aura that's around you you like
the guy said in the song There's an aura
that's around you yeah naturally comes
up to me yeah and the people they come
around they they yeah that's right
there's you feel it I could I could and
they kill guys those people those people
are in every city you know they killed
they killed Hedberg you know like yeah
there's no way Hedberg was ever going to
stop anything because he'd show up and
be like Daddy's here yeah the devil's
Representatives would show up oh they he
as soon as he get to a town by the time
he checked into his hotel it's all set
those messages were in already
poor bastards they get into that zone
where you can't even if you want to get
out you can't get out people expect it
from you so if you told the dealer I
don't I'm I'm not doing it anymore but
they stopped calling her now they'd
still want to come to the show and
they'll come all three nights until they
break you
a good dealer
like if I'm your dealer Lee and you come
to Houston and you say to me uh my wife
just had a kid I haven't done it in 32
days you're done I got you okay that was
why I knew I had to leave when I was
yeah
no the dealer came up to me and I go
what am I gonna do he goes you gotta get
out of here you know when the dealer
says you gotta go you better go oh yeah
imagine he was like you gotta go do your
own thing I'm like okay okay I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go
yeah but like uh how much were you doing
at that point if you don't mind me
asking me yeah I was not like a you know
I would it was just sort of a way of
life in the in that I lived at the store
I lived in the house so we you know we
someone would come with some I'd have a
package
up to the store is that your worst run
that you had for that for that eight
months yeah that was that led to that
that led to me losing my mind yeah that
was the worst run and then after that I
had a guy in New York I got clean for a
while met a chick that married
eventually but I had a guy in New York
but I was like a guy like I was in New
York and the dude was on the Lower East
Side and he you know I'd get over there
early and I think I could get it out of
the way so I do Wednesday Thursday
Friday you know and I just kind of like
I I'd nurse it you know I didn't blow
out unless I went on the road and then I
blow out and I'd come back all beat up
so I had a I always could sort of manage
but I thought I was gonna die and I kind
of wanted to die that was what got me
was that like I can't live like this but
I can't stop so maybe it'd be better if
I just had a heart attack
I didn't want my wife at that time was
my girlfriend I kept saying you know
what
whatever I do I do but some people like
don't deserve to find somebody on the
floor purple right yeah if I'm with uh
if I'm like that I never had rules like
that if you're wondering how much I do I
didn't have that rule like look I love
you I don't want you to find me purple I
just it's just a policy I just thought
about it have you ever found somebody no
not from an old D or anything just
somebody shot in the head somebody got
hit by a car no I don't live at like
stays with you forever it could be a
relative I couldn't imagine being in a
room with four guys who you love with an
eight ball on the floor the hooker comes
on everybody's getting their dick sucked
when somebody goes nothing passes out
you always thought that was gonna happen
that's one of the reasons why I stopped
it's like someone's gonna go down and I
don't want it to be me it was the same
[__] thing it was the same psychology
yeah I kept saying you know what if I
died it wouldn't matter but if she finds
me uh it's gonna stay with this poor
girl forever and she don't deserve this
you know and every morning I wake up
Mark Myron the other guy put Narco on a
friend came over and they're like you
have Norco I want to watch like okay
and then we would talk and I thought
about it how lucky
my life was and all of a sudden today
the chick from uh IMC sent me the
trailer
and I saw a picture of you and I'm like
how lucky are we this [__] guy how
lucky is he that
you got the greatest Second Chance of
all [__] time you and Bernard King
you know black king no play for the
Knicks oh yeah great he went out to the
Golden State Warriors Got The Comeback
player of the year and they got him back
the next and he just destroyed the
league for three years that's what you
did yeah come back [__] play the yeah
how lucky are we that we don't
and the other thing I knew like you know
because I'd let it all go is that like I
would I could show up for work you know
that's the other thing that for whatever
reason
you know by the time I started the
podcast I was like that ain't gonna
happen for me I'm just gonna you know
I'm gonna do this see what happens yeah
this is you know I I'm not you know I
don't sell tickets I'm not going to be a
big comic I'm not gonna have a TV show
but I'm gonna just work and try to make
something happen and I let it go I like
I I just I seriously Let It Go like all
the you know sort of expectation I'm
just sort of like I blew it so now I'm
going to sit in my garage and do this
and just be honest and see what happens
and then it started to come and when I
got the opportunities the one thing I
knew that I would never have known any
other time in my life was like I can do
this I mean I can show up for work I
don't give a [__]
like I can you know I'm not afraid of
this [__] I didn't think this was gonna
happen
and I just you know like so I had a
confidence like I knew the first season
it was going to be dicey with the acting
I knew if I got another season I'd
probably get a little better you know I
just knew all this stuff I'm watching
other guys and then with the stand up
I'm like I know how to do this so I'm
just quick like I'm starting to draw
crowds and I'm like I I used to sit
backstage before I went on I'm like I
got [__] nothing this is gonna suck
that [__] table's [__] how the
[__] you know the milk in the middle
just blew me away what the [__] you know
what this is [__] up and I go out on
stage with that attitude and now like
I'm like I get to a place where I'm
working I'm like I'm just gonna look at
the stage I want to sit up there before
the crowd comes in I'm like this is
gonna be fun you know what I mean like
it all just like you know I'm excited
about it and I don't think that would
have happened in any other time and it
wouldn't have happened had I given a
[__]
because honestly Joe I don't like this
part of me that just doesn't give a [__]
and like and that's like that's
threatening to people because they're
like you know we might want you to like
no I can't yeah maybe I'm not good
it's amazing to say that you don't care
and it's over 700 episodes well no the
podcast is my my heart in my life you
know the podcast is something that me
and my uh business partner and producer
Brendan have complete control over and
that's there and that's its own thing
that became this thing that I could
never have expected and we make a nice
living off it but the other stuff the TV
stuff now when people are like you want
to jump through hoops for anything I'm
like nah really I don't really need to
why would you yeah and so when the when
the opportunity came to do the show and
we did it was like they gave us like
complete creative freedom you know and I
was just with a bunch of guys I was
nervous about things and I made sure the
stories were right and stuff but I just
didn't you know I wasn't afraid of
anything and I didn't see those people
as having power over me anymore that's
the one thing that went away you know
when you got me and my Brendan we
weren't business guys we didn't know
what the [__] a podcast was going to do
or what we just knew we were gonna do it
twice a week and this was going to be
the thing and then as the this model
grew and people started to figure out
how to make a little money we grew with
it and then that was that and then all
of a sudden it's like where we got our
own business so this other [__] is sort
of like yeah maybe I'll do it you know
and that changed everything but it's
like
to have done a TV show it's interesting
I did all the things that a comic wants
to do like you always want to do your
own chart and I did a you know the
comedy specials but it's so funny
because I did it off to the side still
do you know what I mean there wasn't the
network pressure there wasn't the
[__] freaking out it wasn't like my
specials not on HBO so it was this thing
where like I could do it with a certain
amount of peace of mind and a little
more control and like you know do it
exactly the way I want it and the people
that find it find it and that's that
do you think when I walked into [__]
Felicia's garage and did a podcast with
her we'd be here
did you think 20 years ago no podcast
would now do what this did I mean do you
think that the president would be on a
[__] podcast in my house no I mean
who who thought about nobody knew when
we got behind the microphones I had no
idea I was gonna get a job selling cars
were you right down the corner I just
couldn't figure out how to pee in the
bottle Queen because I had that THC did
you talk to the guy though I went over
there yeah I went over there and I
talked to the guy and I told him I had
done this in college and I was got a
closer at Douglas tell you the other guy
goes let me check some references Boom
come and go pee oh thank God and I told
him the truth I said listen man it's hot
so you've got to give me a couple days I
gotta get my your kids pee or something
and that whole thing I started this with
Felicia next thing you know it grew and
we got together with Lee and and it's
just been uh
at times I feel like Justin Bieber
but I know that I've done other things
in the business that I'm not Justin
Bieber I've done movies and TV shows and
[__] and stand up so
I love it listen
what they're paying for TV today like I
just got a guest star off on the [__]
CBS show yeah I'm thinking like eight
days
I can't better go on the road for three
days that's right yeah for three days
and have a great time have a hotel room
and hold a room service right go down
isn't that amazing I'm [__]
believable that you make those choices
like you back in the day you would drop
everything you'd cancel the club cancel
every canceled next week because I want
to rest yeah yeah I'm gonna win an Emmy
for this [__] yeah this is gonna change
my life you burn it you would burn a
bridge at a club to do a [__]
audition
like you would like you you get this
[__] call you'd have a Friday and a
Saturday and they like they need to fly
out today we can't put it on tape and
you're like hey buddy I gotta so you
burn that club and then you go do that's
why I that's why I'm on the road I got
[__] like I never stayed out there in
any consistent way I never knew you had
to build relationships with club Owners
I would take any sort of like
opportunity to try to audition or
whatever and think that was just part of
it and then like I didn't have no you
know I didn't I couldn't go really on
the road
towards the end towards I did the
longest shot in 2005.
and I thought I did The Longest Yard I
[__] went deep
and my body created this anxiety yeah
I just got this weird feeling on [__]
planes
so I was started canceling gigs either a
because of the paranoia getting on the
plane
or B because of auditions how many
[__] weeks I used to cancel yeah
because you want to break I didn't give
up you want to break yeah I didn't give
a [__] I didn't know about the
relationships and the people I didn't
remember and
I used to do horrible things I just told
the story the other night about
like I just used to think like it's all
about me so I remember one time I was in
the this is how I learned this weird
lesson about that you know people have
lives I was at Zanies in Chicago and it
like I didn't try it was nobody you know
and I was headlining though and there
was like 12 people in the room and I was
doing one of those sets where it's like
I was on stage for like an hour and a
half yeah just way over just because I
thought like I'm working [__] out that's
what this is for and I go that's it for
me I'm gonna bring the host back up and
I just hear the bartender from the back
of the room go he went home
I'm like oh that's not oh there's other
people okay lives I could have just got
off at an hour like a [__] Pro but
I'm just gonna drag
[__] Thursday night people down this
hole with me it was it was a sad moment
but you still didn't get I'm not great
with the empathy back then you know and
I'm just sort of like all right I think
I may respect some people it used to be
a club in Beaumont in Texas and I was
friends with Slade for years I love
Slade do we
and he would book me twice a year flying
to Houston do it Thursday night in
[__] Houston and then he's in he's up
in Oregon now right slave him oh sweet
that's his first name that's all you're
talking about the other slave and uh he
bought this room with a partner yeah for
years he did this room he didn't know
his partner was stealing his Coke his
blow for Coke yeah it was a pretty solid
room it was a Houston type crowd they
would come up from New Orleans
to make a long story short I did two
weekends there mark Myron that I still
try to do community service by helping
out Comics to replace what I did there
right okay oh I went there one weekend
and they were just giving me Mexican
Coke that chunk [__] yeah by the pound
yeah I couldn't you know what I'm saying
yeah like chicken it was good it was
tremendous yeah it was just yellowish
you know yeah
[__] another weekend I went and I
tangled up with 30 Valiums and I was
popping the volumes I was laying down on
stage we're being arrested for the
stories we're telling oh please they
were that's the smartest thing they
could do are you ever really do you ever
wake up really [__] happy that this
is not your life anymore dude
how many doors have opened for you since
you said no like okay
well it took a while in sobriety to to
realize that things were better you know
like it takes a long time to just get
your life leveled off and and yeah and
then I was it took
it was all the podcast dude it was all
that you know they were talking 2009
2010 when they started to make a yeah it
was you know before that it was it was
over it was over
okay I really my manager couldn't do
nothing for me booking age and couldn't
do nothing for me it was [__] the
worst divorced
well 2007 2000 you know the divorce
finalized 2007 2008 and I guess you know
I was kind of Tapped Out money-wise had
a little savings and we started doing
the podcast in New York and then uh
I just got in it you know I like this
mic you know I like doing this and and
uh but I didn't we there was no way to
make money and you know comedy gigs
weren't really happening and I had to
erase my uh you know I was involved with
the political dialogue because I was
doing you know the Lefty talk radio but
I didn't want to do that anymore because
it was too narrow and I just wanted to
talk about other things so it took a
couple years to to sort of you know
re-establish or just establish myself in
general and then that's when started
happening you know like because of the
[__] podcast there was just like
years of being people knew me I was in
the game I'd done Conan I'd done
Letterman I've done all that [__] but I
wasn't selling tickets no one knew me
was going to buy tickets I had no draw
I'd know you know I'd had opportunities
I had deals nothing nothing really came
to pass my space you went to I was yeah
I was yeah this is it yeah this is the
nothing I thought that you know I made
some money on air America that first
year because they were just dropping
cash because they you know they didn't
know better so I stashed all that money
and I was the first time I ever made
money that was 2000 four and then she
left me 2006 so all that money [__]
went away and that just really was I
didn't know what I was gonna do if I was
gonna sell the house there was no I used
to do a joke about it it's like um
you know you get to a point where you
know there's no there's no turning back
there's no there was never a plan B
because like you get to you know certain
junctures in your life you sit there and
you're like ah [__] this I could always
nothing there's no there's no nothing
there's nothing there what are you gonna
do
you know so there's that realization you
know like [__] what am I gonna do and
we're proud [__] too that's the
other thing those I don't know how the
[__] people quit this thing I at that
moment I'd rather die than like I'm done
what are you gonna walk away from then
run into people
like hey Joey hey what are you doing now
I I just uh um
a buddy of mine's got furniture store
got nice [__] there mid-century stuff
maybe you come back like there was a one
time where I was in a furniture store
and Jimmy Kimmel came in and and uh you
know I met him a couple times I think
there's as I was doing the podcast
already but I was working on the store
and I think for a second he thought I
worked there and it was like it was so
embarrassing because I went up to a
wedding but did you think I worked there
he's like no no no you did that I worked
at
I don't know how [__] people do that
can't believe you just said this what
yeah and I go to the store
Thursday night
first off about three days before I got
a call from an ax comic
and he's trying to give me an a beating
about a comic today that's kind of hot
yeah I'm I said to him before this goes
on a little while ago the way you give a
[__] yeah well I knew him back then and
now he won't answer my email listen
so you know it just bothered me that
this guy had sent my friends and he I go
down at the time and there's another
dude down there
he quit the store and I put the story
together later on
but he was one of those guys that hung
out at the store every night yeah you
know had stories and you know he might
have get up and he would sign up on the
sign up list and he would torment you
yeah he would torment to the whole
[__] he didn't drink he didn't get
high which made it even worse I'm trying
to work on my [__] son Dan here and
this guy's over here give me any a beat
he's not getting trying to just piss on
you like every [__] night he piss on
your [__] leg Yeah
he's lurking over the years I've heard
he's alert this had to be 2003.
next thing you [__] know I get out of
the car there he is the other night the
other night hey how you doing they never
go away completely what Hey sir you
still come here
and he goes I'm done I walked away from
that was one of the Smart Ones I have
four beautiful girls and really the real
estate business oh yeah everything is
great I look at this place it's falling
apart and I you know I'm old school I
wanted to unlove like what difference
would it make yeah this guy's living in
somehow old Florida telling people when
he so why did he go back just to do that
yeah just to do that that's how he
that's how that idiot wins and you know
you know what you do when that happens
you go up to Eric and go I don't like
that guy said no
don't let that guy oh
I got a call about a month ago from an
angry female comic after she was at the
store and they made her wait online is
there anybody acting cool
at the store
okay I'll get yeah one time I was at the
store and you know for whatever it's
worth you know Candace and whatever
relationship I have with him I respect
him as a comic but he was a bully and he
was not a great guy and he put me
through a lot of [__] as a kid and uh
but like you know his brother Bill you
know whatever you think about it doesn't
matter you know yeah I've never met him
yeah I don't need I read the book but
I've never I never I don't need to throw
nobody under the bus but I knew Bill and
you know what you know it's water under
the bridge in a way but one night I was
at the store it's not too long ago and
bill and his wife they're all dressed up
you know and they're walking around like
they're lost and they're just you know
he goes like what's going on here I
don't know anybody anymore and I was
just sort of like yeah so what happens
you know and he just like Crest falling
and they just I just watched him walk
away and I was like over it's over
they're not it's not your place anymore
you know sometimes like you know that
place the thing about if you have a
relationship with that store like you
like you're happy for it now you're
happy for the [__] building
you're like you know what I mean because
a place was so [__] haunted and so
dark and so weird at different points
for different reasons like you know it's
still haunted no I know the haunt didn't
go away it's not as corn did you go down
the basement never again
they keep calling me to do a podcast
where is it in the basement wait for me
I just I walked down there the first
time the other night I was like look
it's nothing just [__] just boxes of
[__] there's not there's some stuff down
there yeah go and sniff the walls bring
a dog down into this there's bodies I
guarantee what's in those [__] walls
yeah I didn't read too much into it the
one thing I noticed is I've been talking
about that [__] stool in the OR for
two or three months now right it's
[__] up It's Gonna Hurt Somebody But
I'm doing a bit about it so I'm okay
with it and and I talked about it on and
on you know for weeks I went down the
basement for the first time the other
day there's like three [__] new
stools down there just sitting down
there so so God bless them they're like
don't put a new one up Marion's got this
great bit didn't know when I'm [__]
spit up
just sitting down there I don't trust it
downstairs it's all the way to the back
so you guys go to the front where you
can still see daylight right right yeah
that's cool you gotta do Jacques
Cousteau I would have called Blake Clark
you got to go deep back into the
American Waters of the underworld
there's some of those guys that have the
real ghost stories they're all door guys
Blake Harris Pete I gotta track those
guys down I ran into bike I should call
him how long are we doing we're gonna do
with some shout outs we'll do 15 more
minutes I'll get you the [__] out of
here
my main man Matt bake up there in
Bakersfield BJJ Vladimir
Ragnar my man Daniel Lyons Pilates For
Men the book
pearly sweet Lester Chad Rizzy Sean
Begley ookie spooky and a beautiful son
James Harrison Parish Mikey Tabitha
Stevens and DJ
[__] react how you feeling over
there Lee all right yeah it's good
you're out there staring into the
[__] hemisphere well we opened up
with 800 that's a lot I can't believe
like since I quit Coke yeah I got
married yeah I had a kid
I'm out of debt
of course you are
I did the math
of what I was spending towards the end
it was
horrific mark
the last
four years
the last four years crossed my house
afterward the damage was
636 dollars a month for six years we had
we got
the weird thing is I never craved that
[__] oh now never oh no no no no no no
but like some drugs like you know I know
you still do the weed and [__] now like
I don't do nothing except these [__]
nicotine things like occasionally you
know like I I appreciate weed you know
and I think about it but like the blow
what a waste no no no no [__] waste I
told uh if right now I did blow
first off I would just break the promise
that I made to myself
and number two I think I would die
eventually because my life would turn
around that aura would come back oh yeah
you get all sweaty you go right down the
[__]
I would lose my daughter I would lose my
career I just know I'm one of those guys
there's no going back to that yeah I
think I think you should always remember
you lived under a rocket
talking about it
and I felt so bad for myself that that
was the point in my life I was at but I
really thought heroin would cure cocaine
addiction and the whole summer I would
do a line of coke on Mondays but type of
what happens to you Mike married is
you're negotiating with the monster the
demon if you have the demon you're
always in some sort of negotiation with
it that was what Jim Carroll wrote that
about a
you know about it was uh it was
interesting Jim Carroll you know the
chunky poet Min rock guy
after Cobain died he does a line in a
poem he wrote a eulogy to uh to Jim uh
to Kurt Cobain I don't know you could
probably find a Jim Carroll uh eulogy
Kurt Cobain but the line was something
like you know he should have negotiated
with the monkey
and that's all that's what it becomes
it's it's all a negotiation you just got
to figure out what you're gonna live
with you know it's gonna come out
somewhere right it's gonna come out
somewhere did you find it six fragments
yeah probably fragments yeah yeah yeah
yeah what's the monkey line is it
possible to track it it's not that long
a poem
I hope I'm not making it up
but uh
there we go what is it you should have
failed you should have taught more like
you should know you should have talked
more with the monkey he's always willing
to negotiate
the monkey on your [__] back he
should have talked more with the monkey
he's always willing to negotiate he's
going to negotiate with your monkey I'm
always negotiating with my monkey every
[__] day
every [__] day that's who you know
it's like you know you get you go you
deal with the monkey and then you deal
with whatever you think God is you know
what I mean if you don't think it's God
or whatever once you get past a monkey
you got to realize this is what life is
like and I gotta live it you know not
and not end it so Jesus At what age you
know how they're saying that yeah that
you give your life to yeah something or
something like that
you know
I was
29 years old and I go you know what
here's the deal
I get up in the morning I pay my bills I
like to party okay yeah so instead of
throwing away balls a week from now on
I'll do one
yeah I stuck to that for years well
that's how I felt too it's like I'm only
doing it Wednesday through Saturday yeah
no no I would just go one night deep and
Tall
jerking off showers yeah you know you're
gonna make it take three days to pull
back from like when your friends yeah
come over and give you a back rub and
get creepy on the phone yeah you know I
would oh yeah oh yeah you call your best
friend number three unless you gotta
come over oh this is the worst we
jerking off for like four hours like
this I'm winning this is like you know
boy cocaine's great no can't call
anybody now I guess I'll just do this
for [__] three hours that was a girl
from the restaurant we were friends I
knew her parents but I hadn't heard
through the
Grapevine yeah
she was a [__] Savage
a Savage
but before the party I got a call to put
together packages yeah they total it's
like two ounces so I made a ton of money
and I made a ton of blow it's one of
those nights when you're walking around
with like nine grams you're like oh my
God all I need is to bump into a Savage
and I took it to this party and we did a
couple bumps and then went back to my
place and we drank some wine I'll never
forget going I went in the bathroom and
I still had a big rock like I had like a
six and a half gram Rock and I remember
looking at her and thinking about the
Rock and going
so you're gonna go okay you want me to
call a cab for you and she's like okay
uh and she left and I'm in my did that
whole package and jerked off and showers
and bottles of booze and like a week
later I go why did I do that she was
right there yeah
that's how greedy I was this is 19.
greedy but it's also you had full
control of the situation who the hell
knows what let me tell you sir I bumped
into that [__] 99 in Miami and I set
that freak straight Jack he made up oh
my God she was living like in fire like
in one of those cities and she called me
like a week before yeah they're gonna be
at the Miami Improv let me come down and
visit you I'll tell you one day I'll
tell you a story one time I had a
I could come out here man I would come
out that's when I met you I'd come out
for these weeks to do whatever meetings
or whatever and get coke with you know
Bob and now
and one time like I signed up you know
and I don't mention your names doesn't
matter but I end up with this girl who
works at the agency that I'm just about
to start with you know
his way back I'm still using this guy
like 20 years ago 18 years ago and we
end up I'm doing blow and she didn't
know I'm doing well but you know we're
out and we're eating and everything we
end up back our place and I can't
[__] get it up I'm just Coke dick I
can't do nothing and like I try and I
try and I'm like embarrassed because
like you know I'm just gonna be starting
at the end at least I could do it show
up for this but I could not get anxious
and I'm Coke thick and I can't [__] and
I'm like God damn it and we just had to
quit she's just like enough I'm like God
damn it so I left and I went back to the
hotel and I couldn't sleep and I'm like
God damn it I did some more lines I
drank some more and I just then I
stopped and I waited like four hours I
couldn't sleep at six in the morning I
drove back to our house hey I can do it
I can do it like I wake her up and I get
up there and I just [__] really good and
I'm like all right okay we good all
right and then nice to see you and I
left I'm bad so thank God thank you like
how [__] nuts is that like you know
like six in the morning I'm like I'm
ready I'm ready give me another shot and
uh I'm so glad I delivered the goods she
didn't really remember you know I I I I
was thinking so proud of myself it's not
as important a memory to hers it is to
me I was thinking about yeah and I told
Lee this story when I first got divorce
like when we first separated I had tons
of dough in the bank and I had money and
credit cards
[__] it I could sit in my apartment and
whack off I had a condo in Boulder yeah
but across the street from me was a
friend that copped where I cut she was a
nurse and told her Memorial Hospital
I didn't go over at two in the morning
and I'd see her with the blue suits on
copping to go home yeah and we'd say
hello to each other and you know one day
I said let me just [__] take a walk
over there so I would get all coked up
and put like my dog and walk across the
street and walk on the third floor like
I was just looking around and see her on
the couch myself doing the same thing
you were jerking off oh my god with like
a little crack in the window yeah and
she'd be having pajamas in a row but I
could see she's trying to watch TV all
[__] up and I was not gonna die oh my
God are you up on me too come in I go in
there we lay down together like this is
from the first time she's like sit next
to me yeah and then that's like seven
minutes you take my helmet out she'd
suck it yeah she'd put it back in and
she'd keep watching TV like all right
and that was it that was a horror
relationship so but that was a Side
Story I knew her brother yeah
oh I bump into a brother he comes to one
of the Denver shows yeah and he's all
happy and so we're walking recently
Works last year oh yeah he goes hey I
found out about you and my sister he had
a good time both of you is all [__] up
what are you talking and I denied it you
know me yeah that's crazy oh yeah she
used to suck your dick and [__] you and
stuff oh how embarrassing
Reese I got a Christmas card so he's not
mad what happened to her
she married and she's in Boulder and all
right and that was everybody happy
ending Mike Murray I want to
congratulate you and thank you for
coming on this show it was a pleasure
just talking always good to see you
you're always almost sweaty I think I
got a drip yeah I think oh my God
I couldn't handle any of that stuff that
this lifestyle that's going from we're
too old buddy that's another thing we're
too [__] old we made it through
old I think we got a shot to live a long
time like yesterday I hope so I hope so
and [__] Johnny Depp well he's in
he's negotiating you know he doesn't do
that [__] no more but he drinks you know
you get you know you some of you guys
you get your thing and you just sort of
like I'm okay I can live okay on this
and not hurt myself 70 years old yeah I
interviewed him and he was pretty loopy
but it was cute you know I think people
still do blowing things I think he'll do
it occasionally like I bet you he'll do
a bump but he don't do it regular I
think he just sort of kind of does the
the you know alcohol maintenance maybe
some weed but I think on a nice occasion
he'd probably do a line or two
I couldn't even imagine and like I said
I have no desire I lost that aura people
don't offer me no more in towns I don't
go looking for it do you miss it any
part of it
I know I can jerk off for hours without
it
if I need to do I miss any part of it I
you know what you know what you know
what you miss is knowing you're gonna
get it
that's the weird thing you know you know
what you miss is that when you do the
package like that moment we're like that
guy that moment that feeling that like
it's gonna be okay tonight it's gonna be
okay it never is it's never a good time
but no that excitement of when you hang
up the phone I'm coming now
and you're going to get it like that
take a [__] first because your
intestines are emptying and you [__]
everything from Thanksgiving the turkey
leg the [__] cranberry the first the
first line you know no idea the first
line when you like you know you're
getting it and then you go over and the
guy's like I got it and you're like you
put it out and you're like there it is
and you do the first two bumps I miss
that but everything after that I can
live without
I missed the blackout on the drive for
the ATM I love the deal this house I
would just black out I was running red
lights at the end no I don't miss it I
was running red lights at the end Mark
Maron I would not stop I got to the
Hollywood what's the routes rock and
roll Ralphs yeah the ATM there yeah I
would double park right on Sunset like I
own the strip
we're gonna take 60 go right down the
block we're at Western
Sunset and [__] right there on Sunset
rock and roll oh yeah yeah yeah across
from the [__] the hotel there yeah
yeah and I would go shoot down the block
and then that was the original package
yeah if I had extra though on the way
home from the store I go from Padre yeah
and I get the backup back yeah yeah so
the two dealers you know yeah you found
them yeah I had a couple dealers yeah
yeah and then if I ran out of like the
one dealer always had really good Coke
but the one dealer was men's Immortal
from time to time yeah so if I went home
and that dealer was out I'd string it
out to about a quarter or two because I
had a deal but I got off work right
there you had a full-time job oh my God
can you believe this you know a guy once
told me if you think of all the energy
you put into yeah to doing drugs
think of the [__] [__] could happen
you don't do drugs you just and also you
live in a different pace a different
life you enjoy Real things you're not a
[__] animal you're not a freak
because you know when you're in that you
you hang around with people do that and
you think that that's a life and then
like normal people or not even normal
people but even just relatively normal
people like what the [__] are you doing
like I had that horrible moment where
like you know some chick came to visit
me when I was living at Crest Hill and
you know from I knew from college and
we're doing the all night thing and you
know we [__] and it was crazy devil
sex and like you know we were up all
night and she didn't really do that [__]
and I you know I was sitting there going
this amazing man no one [__] lives
like this we're [__] living
and like a few weeks later I get a
handwritten letter basically said you
know no one would want to live like that
you know yeah I don't know what you
think you'd do it I was like oh [__] my
dad you're off the grid you know you're
off the grid you live in an outlaw life
you know
I miss the times I like my sleep now I
like my peace of mind yeah
the peace of mind is the most important
thing that nothing's lurking I'm not
missing nothing right in the last five
years I was just doing it by myself and
jerking off and looking out a window and
now you've got your beautiful kid you
got your cats you got a wife you got
comedy you got friends you got a podcast
you're not all sweaty all the time from
that anyway
and we're doing that show we on the show
together tomorrow night man no Wednesday
night sleep nine o'clock Eastern time
six o'clock Pacific IFC I think it comes
on twice yeah so it comes on twice so
but we get it at six also gotta get the
special cable like you get The Sopranos
at six then the regular people got it at
night right right right the east coast
East Coast food yeah but yeah please
watch it Mark gave me a great
opportunity I want to thank you I love
you brother I love you too I'm just
going to read ads if you want to Skype
doodle you want to wait two minutes
there go ahead let me get what you got
Lisa yet thank you again very much thank
you for having me I love you [__]
gentleman the Scala as usual cool you
know me I love my underwear for years I
went out without underwears I was so
broke now I love underwear so whether
you're wearing a suit or sweats you
spend 24 hours a day in your underwear
but instead of making a statement like
Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes your underwear are probably
boring they got skid marks in them all
that dirty stuff me undies is here to
change that every pair of me undies is
made with substantially sourced modal a
fabric that's twice as soft as cotton
tremendous nothing could describe the
FIT and the feel of me undies but once
you try them on you understand why
they're called the world's most
comfortable underwear when I work out go
to the gym when I go to Jujitsu bam I
got me on these on it keeps my nut sack
fresh no moisture it pulls it out of
there and if you don't love your first
prayer me undies
they're free no questions asked like I
said nothing describes the fit and feel
of me undies but once you try them on
baboon me undies has dozens of styles
limited edition prints to help you make
a statement with your undies okay
whether anyone can see them or not
remember Superman all right the party's
over this is what I'm gonna do as member
of the church shipping is free in the US
and Canada so you can save up to eight
dollars a pair with the me on the
subscription plan get to me on the
subscription or a single pair get 20 off
your first order when you go to
meanders.com Joey again
twenty percent off your first daughter
when you go to meandies.com Joey that's
me on these.com slash Joey I'm giving
you 20 off all right I want to thank me
undies number two listen we all love
magazines you know Mark's got glasses he
likes magazines when you get on a plane
yeah we like reading Rolling Stones yeah
but sometimes you look around with
stones and uh I buy Rolling Stones
sometimes for one [__] article yeah
and that's it you look at the pictures
of pictures here here's Johnny Collins
yeah you know with [__] Bruce
Springsteen for sure yeah that's it
after that you're like what the [__] did
I get the rest this for to read about
Rihanna and getting tackled people I
don't know I don't need this aggravation
in my [__] life all right here's the
beauty of it thanks to Pizza all binge
eating thanks to Netflix wall been binge
watching but now with texture you could
start binge reading trust me it's about
to be the big thing when it comes to
magazines you know what you like and
with texture you can get all the
magazine you want in one super
convenient place Texas has completely
reimagined magazines re-imaged magazines
reimagined what the [__] am I talking
about I gotta stop smoking reefer re
image magazines give me the Articles and
stories you really want all in one place
plus interactive features videos and
recommendations just for you the texture
app lets you tap into the world's most
popular magazine anytime anywhere using
your smartphone on your tablet if you're
gonna fly you download what you want you
bring it up on the plane there you go
Breeze through hundreds of your favorite
magazines including back issues and pick
the articles that interest you the most
texture has made it easy to find
articles you care about listen I I don't
just want to read uh Rolling Stone and
uh mechanics what's that mechanic thing
you like to really uh what the [__] is
it Motor Trend I'm sorry Motor Trend
mechanics
editorial team recommends content for me
every day plus I can dive deeper into
the personalized collections all right
do me a favor sign up for texture right
now and gain insight into all the
content from the world's best
Publications I'm talking ESPN magazine
or recipes Domino PC Magazine prevention
Men's Journal men's fitness
blah blah blah blah I mean they got
everything hello
Cosmopolitan Latina you know they got
everything on here so do yourself a
favor and do me a favor go to texture
right now for a free trial when you go
to techshit.com Joey you gain immediate
entry into all the top magazines
including back issues and bonus video
content start binge reading for free
right now on me when you go to
texture.com Joey that's texture.com Joey
how you like that Mark good job I'm a
[__] Savage you know why swoop Tech
from [__] uh on it the quadricep
mushrooms spam my lungs because they
grow it up in the High Altitude and
that's why I could talk [__] for two
[__] hours if not I'd be over here
dying already
so do me a favor go to honor.com take a
look at the Alpha Brain or the hemp
Force
protein what do they get what's the code
they get the code is church and they get
10 off c-h-u-r-ch I want to thank my
main man Mark Maron don't forget the
episodes called Philippe Wednesday night
the eighth six uh p.m California time 9
P.M
6 p.m if you got the Eastern feed that's
right if not you got to wait 99 like the
[__] regular people and uh yeah on
Silver Lake I love you guys thank you
very much for listening tonight thank
you Mark thank you Joe
oh oh Thursday Friday I'll see you
[__] in Omaha Nebraska at the
Funny Bone what in two weeks I'll be in
Philadelphia helium you [__] dirty
[__] get ready I'm coming to your
town I'll see you Friday night two shows
Saturday two shows
funny bone
Omaha [__] Nebraska sponsored
by 10th Planet [__] Omar I see
you [__] there
I always forget the plug myself
you you ever play that Cliff which one
no
foreign
thank you
[Music]